on appelle cette période américaine de
prospérité le gears 2 days l'équivalent
de la belle époque
dans les dernières années du 19e siècle
les immigrants arrivent par bateau plein
à ellis island
ils vont peupler les quartiers
populaires de new york tandis que les
hommes d'affaires prospères construisez
gratte-ciel et l'industrie lourde tourne
à plein régime sur la côte ouest et
chercheur d'or s'embarque pour le
klondike le krach financier de 1893 et
oublié on est en 1897
c'est un et l'a envoyée mais clean et
devient président cet avocat
représentant puis gouverneur de l'ohio a
été couronné à la tête du parti
républicain grâce à une influence de
marque sanaa sénateurs et gros patrons
d'industrie il est partisan de tarifs
douaniers pour protéger l'industrie et
défend l'étalon or alors que son
adversaire william jennings bryan
s'épuise à parcourir le pays
il reste chez lui à canton en ohio et ce
sont les gens qui viennent le voir aux
frais du parti
il a inventé la campagne de peron les
délégations de différence et à vienne
leur encontre et donc on pourrait lui
poser des questions et on estime que
comme ceux assis sur son perron il
aurait parlé avec environ 700 mille
partisans au cours de la campagne 2002
1896 qui était tout à fait inédit et qui
s'est avérée une stratégie assez
efficace parce que bon avec tout ça ça
crée une sorte de publicité finalement
qu'ils diffusent et à la grandeur du
pays donc ça lui a permis de remporter
assez facilement l'élection de 1896
oui les mecs ils y prêtent serment en
mars 1897
c'est la guerre à cuba la répression de
l'armée espagnole contre les rebelles
cubain émeut l'opinion publique mais
qu'il est qu'il ne veut pas la guerre
demande à l'espagne d'abandonner cuba
elle refuse le cuirassé américain mêne
explose dans le port de la havane et
washington déclare la guerre la presse à
grand tirage de william randolph hearst
est ravi un certain teddy roosevelt se
rend célèbre à la tête des volontaires
des rough riders une splendide petite
guerre dira-t-on l'espagne est écrasée
sur terre comme sur mer
elle perd porto rico guam et les
philippines qui deviennent des colonies
américaines plus bas reste indépendante
mais sous contrôle de l'armée américaine
et c'est vraiment pour tous les
historiens la diplomatie américaine 1898
l'aller la guerre avec l'espagne c'est
aujourd'hui comme une date de coupures
majeures
c'est vraiment le moment où les états
unis deviennent puissance mondiale et ne
sont plus seulement une nation en
émergence qui est en train de se
construire à l'intérieur de ses
frontières
en prime les états unis s'offrent
l'archipel d'hawaï mais qu'il l'est et
réélu triomphalement est prête serment à
nouveau en 1901 événements qui sont
filmés par thomas cdsn l'inventeur
prolifique dont les parents viennent du
canada
mais à peine six mois plus tard mais
qu'il l'ait se rend à l'exposition
panaméricains de bois flou où il
prononce son dernier discours il parle
de prospérité à la ville et à la fin de
son discours il réaffirme la nécessité
de construire le canal interocéanique de
panama
mais qui est né peu après assassiné par
un anarchiste d'origine polonaise de
deux balles de revolver il mourra
quelques jours plus tard
williams et qui nie le troisième
président à mourir assassiné les
services secrets américains sont créés
suite à l'attentât
son vice-président et theodore roosevelt
célèbre depuis la guerre avec l'espagne
les navires de guerre américains ont
besoin de passer rapidement d'un océan à
l'autre
c'est lui qui aura l'honneur de
construire le canal de panama sa gloire
effacera dans le public le souvenir du
président mais qu'il l'est qui pourtant
à changer la face des états unis et du
monde et c'est pas parce que c'est un
président un conséquent ou incompétents
mais c'est vraiment juste qu'il était
dans l'ombre d'un personnage beaucoup
plus grand que lui teddy roosevelt le
numéro quatre du mont rushmore sera à
président flamboyant et plus
progressiste que son prédécesseur